hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica it's
almost getting the night but it's not
quite there yet so it leaves me just
enough time to venture in the direction
that I have not gone before and
hopefully I'll be able to follow that
guys no I mean you're weird and don't be
looking I'm gonna I'm gonna zoom you're
much stupider than the other fish
because you couldn't get away from me I
mean if anything can be caught by me
then it must be pretty dumb but besides
that obvious fact of me being of a
certain level of intelligence I need to
keep going and fine for this hey why are
you in my way is there something in
there that wants to come out and eat me
probably I still need to find some salt
but I I don't know like I don't know
where things are that's a noise hey
buddy have you seen any whoa your new
are you bad I'm gonna steal you almost
Elia come here yeah that's right
oh you run huh I'm king of this jungle
ocean nighttime approaches and I'm
assuming with with the nighttime comes
bad things I just need some salt oh no
you are dangerous oh it's probably
dangerous isn't it hey you stay away
from me oh god no do not I will wreck
your [ __ ] brah
don't try me I'm ripped huh oh god you
okay sorry I panicked a little bit yeah
yeah yeah maybe if I dig sand I'll find
soul
you recommend a lot of things computer
wife you recommended that I drop out of
college and take care of the baby and
look where I got us
we're loading an ocean on an alien
planet how can you say this better for
Chester jr. I'm delirious
once again dehydration
very bad I cannot find any salt you
think that in a giant ocean I'd be able
to find some salt
oh well apparently not let's go cook up
the random weird fish OPCON I just want
to be older all right I'm gonna come
back when I get a builder because I'm
not I'm not putting you guys through
this it wouldn't be rad I think I see
some salt Oh
so does it like deposit in these little
coral areas okay whatever I got some
salt so that's good for me so now that I
have some salt that means that I can
make some water eyes means I can make
some bleach first but then I can make
some water I got the bleach yeah cool
now yes finally god damn time and it's
almost daytime
all right the guide says if there's
silver on the ground in here which is
scary because there's alien fish okay so
there should be stuff in here I don't
know if these limestone outcroppings
will be different but from what I saw
they would just be on the ground said in
the kelp forest right oh are you
dangerous I'm gonna assume you're
dangerous until you prove safe and then
I'm gonna eat you because that's how I
handle everything in here Oh down here
ooh this looks promising
Oh how about we be friends huh how about
we be friends
I like friends fine seed maybe that has
water in it maybe has something I could
use maybe it has something that I could
plant I mean they'd be oddly beautiful
if they weren't so freaking terrifying I
mean I don't care if it's a plant plants
are scary if they're I don't know if
that's useful okay yes shut up I got boo
what are you you're big me no likey me
no likey you you eat me up gobble gobble
ome communicating caveman speak maybe
you understand meanwhile he's just like
what is that guy rambling about
I have no time to deal with his kind all
your big and scary I don't like you I'm
gonna assume your malevolent you're
gonna eat me in one gulp if I even give
you the slightest chance wish I won't
silver oh my god I found silver I found
silver might as well get as much as I
can forget this torille crap
hoo hoo hoo that's capital there's a
thingy Hey oh god what happened there
where they're just rocks falling do bad
[ __ ] you what the [ __ ] oh my god you
wanna go bro huh I don't know what the
hell I saw there's so many wondrous and
beautiful and weird things happening in
the ocean all the time and it grosses me
out oh I got my silver that's all I care
about good for me ok so now that I got
my silver I can make my builder I can
never go to that area ever again and I
never ever ever have to see those
weird-ass creatures and the piranha
thing is that we're trying to eat my
face and it got plenty of salt I think I
need some creep back don't I do those in
case I need a first aid kit or something
let me just drop coppers for comedy okay
thank you wait did I get any thank you
enough for me okay we're good let's go
home
maybe I don't know if I should build my
base like close to here I should
probably build my base much farther from
here that's the only thing that would
makes sense
let's first things first let's mix
bleach its water in me second things
second okay
now let's make the computer chip got
that okay computer chip fabricated okay
so now I just need beep
battery I thought I had a battery I drop
it like a goober
I need the acid mushroom okay so let me
just drink my water I'll go grab that
rubber get that done the Builder yes
okay this is a big step for me finally
man it would have been impossible to
find that silver without a guide I would
have given up and gone all over the
place okay so I got a builder and that's
totally fine so that means now that I
can build what I need to build and I'm
gonna build my stuff far away I'm
probably gonna build it on the outskirts
of the kelp forest because that seems to
be like a place that actually needs me
to be near him here's my storage cube
that have did absolutely nothing for me
as far as I know anyway okay so if I
build it like
that is creepy okay but okay I got the
Builder I'm out of titanium god damn it
where's my titanium pound hello buddies
hello my babies hello my babies did you
miss daddy I thought I had more titanium
than that did any of you run away you
wouldn't do run away from do anywhere
over there that's a titanium I wanted
okay is that enough for me that's enough
for now I will forgive you later
for running away from your daddy before
now I'm happy that you are here and then
later on we're gonna get some ice cream
or something
boink that's a proper foundation that's
probably important okay damn I keep
forgetting that I need oxygen so bad but
if I can get something down here because
I remember seeing about the two piping
then I should be able to get something
relatively good going and then I can
have something that will finally be mine
a base of operations to expand and make
it my own
okay how do I get in can I get in and
all I cannot get in okay I'm gonna
figure that out and just
I got five pops I don't know what I'm
gonna do with five pass but I got it
okay I need a lot more titanium well if
I only knew now I would have needed a
lot more titanium I would have been a
little more meticulous about it and I
have titanium ingots I have two titanium
ingots this ol fancies still suited for
claims moisture from the body hey I got
a new suit oh-oh I filled my inventory
with pipe I need more silicone anyway
Damon if I'd have known I've got so much
to so many titanium II okay well that
was spooky
okay so this is a good stopping point
for this episode here I have a base
built now
I found the silver I solved my water
problem I have a suit it's all going
very well for me so thank you everybody
so much for watching I will continue
this in just a little bit I'm having a
lot of fun with this game it's really
cool there's a lot to do and a lot to
learn and I'm having a great time
exploring and spending time with Karen
and that right computer wife thank you
everybody so much for watching and if
you got any suggestions let me know in
the comments below thanks again and as
always Oh see you
that's all I could say now what the hell
that's all